so Tyson Fury you're done Deonte you've
dropped a few kilos practice a few moves
you've got off Muhammad Ali so they say
you're the best in the world and like
Tiger Woods you've got a story of
disgrace depression courage and
redemption but they'll probably become a
Hollywood movie but when you come out
with stuff like you're gonna celebrate
your win with cocaine and hookers and
that the best place for a woman is on
her back I say hang about is this the
sort of bloke we should be honoring with
knighthoods after all being good with
your fists doesn't necessarily make you
a great role model so what's a rule here
should we say arise so Geoffrey Boycott
we can forget that conviction for
assault it's been so long
he's you're gone or take Ben Stokes OBE
this week we can forgive and forget what
happens off the pitch as long as you're
a winner on it some understandably think
the gypsy king should face eternal shame
but I believe that where there's
contrition there can be redemption even
for a big tub of lard like you Tyson
just mind your manners or I'll send
Ferrari round brilliant result for him
and for the country delighted for him
and I think you've touched on actually
one of the most interesting aspects of
possibly the whole the whole week
because who is the judge and all the
jury who decides in someone's boycott so
he's always denied that I'd ever took
place but he went on and he indeed got
that but for every Tyson Fury who
appears to have been forgiven and we
never there's a Danny Baker the
broadcaster from whom we most likely
will never hear again he's now been
sanctioned and out and in the court of
public opinion he's deemed a non-person
and I think it's very very dangerous
if there are criminal aspects then it
amused to a different level but I
actually before I yield I celebrated his
victory and I celebrated the fact that
he's been redeemed because I think we
are very very dangerous we're in a place
now where people say things which are
inexcusable they subsequently apologise
I think we need more tolerance of
intolerance yeah I'm with that and I
feel uncomfortable about a guy who has
said these things and defended them when
he said them four or five years ago
particularly the thing about women in
the kitchen and all of that and he made
up a story it's all about his wife I
feel uncomfortable but what you have to
say is that the guy since then has
appeared to be contrite and there's a
point at which you have to say honestly
you can't hold things against people
forever now there are some places where
I don't know if that rule will ever will
ever apply Prince Andrew I'm almost
certain
Harvey Weinstein can never be really
irritated I think the interesting thing
and the important thing my criminal
conviction has been actually he hadn't
been convicted I suspect he would never
I think the point is we need to have
some rules of understanding about this
because otherwise what now happened what
I worry about is that we end up with the
rule of the mob or the rule of the
tabloid and people who may have made
some mistake just get blank for the rest
of their lives simply because the editor
of a newspaper doesn't like me I think
while moving to a culture where people
are judged and this is particularly
scary for all of us not on their deeds
but on their words and we've seen the
rise of canceled culture so and offense
archaeology whereby whatever you've said
going back your entire career can be
used against you to eliminate you really
from your job or from public life as we
saw from Danny Baker and I genuinely
think I mean I don't want to be an
offensive archaeologist myself and say
when did Tyson's fury say that and when
did he apologize because I genuinely
think we have to celebrate
Tyson Fury's achievements and he's just
not in the same category as Harvey
Weinstein or Roman Polanski or someone
who's actually admitted to a crime and
been in remote Roman Polanski's get
convicted of a crime I just don't think
that we can discount Tyson's Furies
incredible achievements because he is a
testosterone phew
old athlete and when we watch the rugby
and we see the England team fighting
another team in the Six Nations you know
they come to fisticuffs on the pitch and
we all realize that men are pumped up
they become very aggressive in the heat
of the moment and that actually bleeds
into the things they say you know look
at think of Muhammad Ali who you mention
always denied that's just to say that
when we just hear from somebody who
speaks up for Tyson Fury
please come back from as I say obesity
huge obesity mental health issues you
know he's a triumph for being fit and
fighting using his fighting spirit to
overcome his human frailty if you like
the desire is to be the number one in
the world and he really has become
cemented his position if there was
boxing commentator Gareth Davies who was
in the Tyson Fury corner after the Las
Vegas what why I feel uneasy about this
though I am for redemption is that I I
worry about people being given
Redemption because they're winners you
know what you can't have is a situation
where somebody does something really
morally reprehensible it may not be
unlawful but morally reprehensible but
two years later we we forget all of that
because they have won some competition
being the best batsmen or the sprinter
or whatever it is doesn't make up for
being an a-plus no I'm you know this
whole notion of role model Tyson Fury
is a sportsman and an incredibly good
sportsman who will go down in history
I'm absolutely sure of it
but then what we do in society is
because someone is a friend in this case
fantastic sportsman we then hold them up
as a role model and to call him and I'm
just saying let's not let's not set make
being able to win at games
get-out-of-jail-free card
and unacceptable moral behavior my point
is that some of the views that he
expresses they are he's quite a
religious person he's also from a
particular culture which differs very
much certainly from mine and he has a
viewpoint and an outlook one which I
disagree with I don't share a lot of his
values or a lot of their traditions or
sentiments and belief system but does
that make him a bad person because I'm
particularly in favor of free speech I
might not like what you say I might even
be offended like some of the comments
that he says about a woman michael--ah
yes I do not believe is in the kitchen
and on my back
I don't describe to that notion at all I
found it a bit offensive but he's
allowed to have that view
if indeed that's his a view and we
should be allowed to disagree with him
we don't have to cancel him and be I
don't know so critical of him I admire
him as a sportsman but I disagree with
some of his views but I respect his
right to hold him Rachel I think it goes
a little beyond his right to say things
which obviously he does have I mean
we're looking at somebody who I mean his
talent and his skill is not in dispute
but we're not just talking about his
sporting achievements we're talking
about somebody who is now being held up
as a role model he's a manatee and in
that context you know I do believe in in
remedial power I do think people have a
right look we're all capable of you know
saying clumsy things or being
thoughtless or being careless but there
is something about acknowledgement of
that taking place which I do not see
with Tyson Fury and I would like to
remind you that these comments that he's
made it's not just a difference of
opinion
these are homophobic sexist anti-semitic
comments made by somebody who is in
public life and will have an impact on
those communities on those people
especially and in particular people who
are thinking about getting into sport
and will think it's not it's not a safe
environment for them just take it away
from the blue corner briefly just remind
everybody who's Ben Stokes was never
convicted of anything is there a dynamic
here because of Tyson Fury's background
let's see what he's writes in behind the
mask my autobiography I was aware of
races
against travelers this may be an
outsider so I felt that for me to get
the attention I needed to be an
attraction in the sport I had to play
the outlaw I felt I had to act out a
role to seek publicity and to do that I
had to be controversial and shock people
with how I talked to some degree it
worked but playing the role got to the
point where I didn't know what was real
and what was the act Richard III I think
he is just breaks when I write said if
he does have a parade through more
command there is a statute put up to him
because of his J he's there a role model
isn't he which is what they're talking
about
well there are I mean as we've discussed
before on the pledge there are countless
statues of people in public life who
have subsequently been shown to have had
done reprehend I don't think I would I
think what Rachel was saying was
interesting because I think the context
of that is he's been nominated for
Sports Personality be spotty and
therefore you know we have to consider
whether you have to consider him in the
round as a person as a personality as
well as as a sporting hero and I think
that does raise a question if we look at
the odd right now is the favorite force
much personality of the year and when we
say personality we're not just saying
best person at doing their sport we're
saying this is a person that we as a
native want to honor and I feel really
quite uneasy without some really major
level of contrition honoring somebody as
sport personality as opposed to sports
you know sports practitioner of the year